trying to think about what Easter means
to me as a Oh chocolate finding
chocolate like two years later
underneath oh yeah we had Easter hunt
and it was great and my mom was very
organized so she wouldn't forget where
she put chocolates but every once in a
while she'd forget one and they would be
like you know you'd find a chocolate
like a moldy chocolate three years later
just hanging out on the on the bookshelf
happy Easter my lovely peeps I'm really
excited about this Easter partially
because I am giving birth that week Oh
kind of nerve-wracking but really
exciting so while you guys are watching
this at home I might be in the hospital
pushing my own little egg out I don't
know we're gonna see now I'll tell you
that might not be the best visual right
now but what is a pretty awesome visual
is chocolate and today we're gonna be
making some vegan gluten-free chocolate
eggs they are really colorful they're
super fun to put together with your kids
and they really bring me back to my
childhood because my mom is a bit of a
Martha Stewart and she would plant the
most amazing chocolate egg hunts and I'm
hoping I'll take after her and do the
same for my little ones one day so guys
let's do this
to sauce pot I add some almond butter
and maple syrup and give it a good stir
over medium heat until everything comes
together and melts down then to a bowl I
combine some brown rice cereal shredded
unsweetened coconut ground flax seed and
my maple almond mixture and I give
everything a really good stir until it
all packs together and is nicely
combined then I pack it into a clique
shapes really really tight and place
them onto a baking sheet lined with
parchment paper or a Silpat set it aside
and let's make some chocolate over a
double boiler I melt some cocoa butter
and some coconut oil and I give that a
stir until it melts to a nice clear
consistency then I pour that into a
bigger bowl add some vanilla extract and
lots of powdered sugar and just give it
a good whisk until it all comes together
then I just transfer it to a few
different little bowls and color each of
them differently using natural food
coloring
[Music]
and now it's time to decorate drop each
of your little Easter eggs into one of
the bowls with a colored white chocolate
making sure to coat it completely all
the way around then transfer it to the
baking sheet with the parchment paper
next transfer any remaining white
chocolate to some piping bags and add
all of your favorite shapes and decor
[Music]
finally it's not an easter egg without
some fun candy so get out your favorites
and decorate let your eggs cool in the
refrigerator until totally set before
transferring them to a cute little
Easter basket for serving enjoy
[Music]
look how cute these little Easter eggs
are honestly almost too cute eat but not
because they've got chocolate and
sprinkles and all the good stuff so I'm
definitely gonna be digging in all right
away not waiting for the kids not
waiting for the hunt at all so if you
love this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below some
of your favorite Easter traditions
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]